* Klagender, wortloser Frauengesang *
Kennst du deinen Berg?
- Wolltest du dich einreihen?
Ich war lange nicht mehr so froh,
diesen verdammten Hügel zu sehen.
* Jubelruf *
Danke vielmals.
- Das war gut.
Super.
Merci. Danke.
David, danke für alles.
- Merci.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Frankreich, Mont-Blanc-Gebiet.
Sieben Menschen sind aufgebrochen,
um sich einen Traum zu erfüllen.
Es ist ihr erster Tag
auf der berühmten Haute Route,
einer Skitour quer durch die Alpen,
von Chamonix nach Zermatt.
80 km, 7'000 Höhenmeter -
in sechs Tagen von Hütte zu Hütte.
Gut, packt mal die Felle weg!
Ihr könnt auch reinkommen.
Die Gruppe
sieht sich heute zum ersten Mal.
Mit dabei: Olympiasiegerin und ehema-
lige Weltcupfahrerin Dominique Gisin
sowie ihre frühere Skirennfahr-
kollegin Fränzi Aufdenblatten.
Vielleicht Severin.
David Fasel ist ihr Bergführer,
zusammen mit Bruno Jelk,
dem ehemaligen Rettungschef
von Zermatt.
Auch dabei:
der CEO der Allianz-Gruppe Schweiz,
ein Heilpädagoge,
eine Tochter mit ihrem Vater
und eine junge Frau, die in Gedenken
an ihre verstorbene Mutter
auf der Tour dabei ist.
Ich war lange nicht mehr
in einem Schullager.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Die Haute Route
durch die höchsten Berge der Alpen -
ein Mythos auf der ganzen Welt.
Eine Herausforderung für alle,
die sie wagen.
Vor ihnen liegen lange Tage,
in denen sie
an ihre Grenzen kommen werden.
Nur als Team
können sie die Strecke meistern.
... die Cabane du Trient.
Es ist ihr erster gemeinsamer Abend.
Alle sind gespannt,
mit wem sie unterwegs sind.
Ich arbeite 80 % bei Swisscom.
Und daneben studiere ich Wirtschaft.
Und ich habe Familie in Zermatt,
meinen Freund in Brig,
ich wohne in Bern und ...
Das alles mit den schönen Ver-
pflichtungen meines früheren Lebens.
Ja, vielleicht mal Zeit haben,
ein wenig über mich
und das Leben nachzudenken.
Wenn man mal am Anschlag ist, kommen
vielleicht all die Sachen raus,
die man im Alltag
gar nicht so weit kommen lässt.
Ich habe auch schon vor einer Weile
mit Skifahren aufgehört.
Im Moment studiere ich Physik
an der ETH Zürich.
Ich befinde mich im Endspurt
meiner Berufspilotenausbildung.
Das ist
eine meiner Langzeitleidenschaften.
Ich meine, was Fränzi gesagt hat,
ist bei mir schon auch ein Thema.
Für mich ist es
auch immer Lebensqualität,
sich mal eine Woche zu nehmen -
sei das auf der Haute Route
oder eine Woche Windsurfen.
Das ist für mich auch wichtig.
Ich habe nach 30 Jahren Arbeit
an einer Schule
die Entscheidung getroffen,
zu kündigen.
Ich höre dort mit der Arbeit auf
und versuche,
mich selbstständig zu machen.
Und damit habe ich mich
auch entschieden, mutiger zu werden.
Ich habe mich bis jetzt nicht so
als mutigen Menschen erlebt.
Ich habe jetzt also
diese Entscheidung getroffen,
und die Entscheidung, auf die Haute
Route zu gehen, hat damit zu tun.
Bei mir war die zeitliche
Verfügbarkeit ein Hindernis, also:
Kann ich mich einfach für eine Woche
aus dem Büro verabschieden?
Wir haben diese Woche ...
Morgen haben wir eine
Verwaltungsratssitzung dieser Firma,
übermorgen ist eine
Geschäftsleitungssitzung usw.
Ich musste mich organisieren,
also Stellvertreter besorgen -
oder solche, die mir einfach helfen,
diese Zeit zu überbrücken.
Das ist mir gelungen, und darum
habe ich definitiv zugesagt.
Ich bin alleinerziehende Mutter
von zwei kleinen Jungs -
sie sind dreieinhalb
und fünfeinhalb.
Ich arbeite 60 %
als Oberstufenlehrerin.
Meine Freizeit beschränkt sich
auf sehr wenige Tage im Monat,
an denen ich
noch wirklich etwas tun kann.
Ich war vor 50 Jahren schon mal
auf der Haute Route und ...
... es hat mich immer interessiert,
wie es heute aussieht -
die ganze Umgebung.
Für mich ist das
die letzte Gelegenheit,
noch einmal
auf die Haute Route zu gehen.
Ich habe die Tourenski
quasi von meiner Mutter geerbt.
Dann waren diese Ski da,
und das hat schon auch
den Reiz ausgelöst.
Was hat sie dazu gebracht?
Wieso hat sie so gerne
Skitouren gemacht?
Ich will das nachfühlen.
Das ist das Besondere.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Auf der Haute Route wollen alle
eine Auszeit von ihrem Alltag nehmen.
Bergführer David Fasel aus Verbier
führt seit Jahren regelmässig
Gäste über diese Route.
Der Start zur Tour war heute Morgen
in Argentiere neben Chamonix.
Von dort ging es hoch
zur Argentierehütte.
Morgen wird die Gruppe zur Cabane
du Trient in der Schweiz weitergehen,
dann über Verbier
hoch zur Cabane Mont Fort.
Von dort in die Cabane des Dix,
ins Bivouac de Bouquetin.
Die Ankunft
ist am sechsten Tag in Zermatt.
Auf das Team warten 7'000 Höhenmeter,
80 km, meistens auf 3'000 m Höhe
inmitten der Viertausender.
Am besten seid ihr um 5 Uhr hier.
Ich stehe um 4.45 Uhr auf.
Ihr müsst selbst schauen.
Am besten packt ihr
heute Abend schon den Rucksack.
Es sind schon noch
einige Leute hier.
Am Morgen wird es hektisch.
Tipptopp, danke.
* Klagender Frauengesang *
* Sie sagt nichts. *
Morgen. Nicht so wach?
Mein Magen spinnt.
- Nein!
Ich hab kein Auge zugetan.
- Nicht im Ernst. Vom Abendessen?
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Der nächste Morgen beginnt
mit einer unangenehmen Überraschung.
Gut geschlafen?
- Nein, es hat mir den Magen ...
Es hat meinen Magen ...
War dir schlecht?
- Ja.
Richtig übel. Etwas war nicht gut.
Bist du auf dem WC gelandet?
- Ja, eben erbrechen.
Ich mache heute langsam.
David Fasel wird heute
mehr Verantwortung übernehmen müssen.
Jetzt, die Felle.
Haben alle ein Fell dabei?
Den Pickel?
- Ja.
Steigeisen?
Das ist so das Wichtigste.
Wir rutschen hier gerade runter.
Einfach langsam gehen und
etwas Distanz zwischen euch lassen!
Bruno, bis da unten,
wo wir dann die Felle montieren,
gehen wir zusammen.
Ich gehe voraus, du folgst.
Dann gehen wir einfach gemütlich.
Ist gut?
Das Wetter ist gut. Ihr werdet
sehen, das wird ein super Tag. Also!
Hopp! Testet mal die Skis
und schaut, ob sie halten!
Noch einmal beide Seiten!
Gut, auf geht's!
Der Schnee ist
nach einer eiskalten Nacht steinhart,
und die erste Abfahrt
führt durch steiles Gelände.
Vor solchen Passagen
hatte der 72-jährige Paul Zeller
bereits im Vorfeld Respekt.
* Spannende Musik *
(Paul) Verdammt noch mal!
Paul, aufstehen! Aufstehen!
- Verdammt noch mal!
CEO Severin Moser muss eingreifen.
Nimm die Ski noch mal zurück!
Mach den Ski auch parallel!
So ist gut.
Er hilft, damit Paul nicht
in die steilen Felsen abrutscht.
(Severin) So, komm nur!
- (Paul) Ja.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Ich bin gestürzt.
Aber ... es geht schon.
Die nächste Schwierigkeit
wartet bereits:
der Aufstieg zum Col du Chardonnet.
Die kämpfen da oben ziemlich
mit den Harscheisen.
Planänderung! Steigeisen an und
die Skis auf den Rucksack schnallen!
Die wenigsten haben bisher
viel Erfahrung
mit dem Gehen auf Steigeisen.
Habe ich das richtig eingefädelt?
Ja.
Jetzt muss ich das so ...
Ich habe
zum ersten Mal Steigeisen an
und zum zweiten Mal
Skis auf dem Rücken.
Aber eine so lange Passage
habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Aufgebrochen ist die Gruppe
heute in der Argentierehütte.
Jetzt sind sie
auf dem ersten Aufstieg
auf den Col du Chardonnet.
Weiter geht's
über das Fenetre de Saleinaz
zur Besteigung der Aiguille du Tour.
Ziel ist die Cabane du Trient
auf 3'170 m.
Über 10 km und 1'040 Höhenmeter
beinhaltet dieser Tag.
Dafür
sind 5-7 Std. reine Laufzeit geplant.
* Klagender Frauengesang *
Ihr müsst die Stöcke gut festhalten!
Es sind auch schon
Stöcke fallen gelassen worden.
Es ist der erste Test.
Bergführer David muss herausfinden,
wie sicher die Gruppe unterwegs ist.
Das war gerade eine Stelle,
an der man nicht ausrutschen sollte.
Es würde nicht viel passieren,
aber so ein paar blaue Flecken
hätte man danach schon.
Aber dafür, dass Peter
zum ersten Mal mit Steigeisen geht,
geht das ganz gut.
(Yolanda) Wie geht's dir, Papi?
- Ja, so weit gut.
Es ist einfach etwas steil.
Ich habe keine Angst,
aber das Atmen ...
* Er keucht. *
Direkt hinter dem 72-jährigen Paul
ist seine Tochter Yolanda.
Jeder sucht seinen eigenen Rhythmus
in knapp 3'000 m Höhe -
nicht nur Carmen und Peter,
sondern auch die ehemalige
Spitzensportlerin Dominique Gisin.
Bruno Jelk folgt, geschwächt
von seiner Magenverstimmung.
Gleich etwas trinken!
Legt eure Sonnenbrillen
nicht zu weit weg!
Wir brauchen sie
vielleicht plötzlich.
Langsam gehen,
einfach langsam gehen!
Es hat keinen Sinn, sich zu beeilen.
Sonst bringt's nichts.
Ich würde am liebsten
gleich mit Steigeisen weitergehen.
Es gefällt mir nicht,
dass wir Felle aufziehen müssen.
Warum?
- Es gibt eine andere Sicherheit.
Es ist früher Morgen
und mit der Spitzkehre ...
Ich fühle mich so sicherer,
und es ist angenehmer,
wenn es gerade schon läuft.
Felle aufziehen
und Harscheisen montieren.
Dominique
greift Fränzi unter die Arme.
Das ist das Blöde
ohne Servicemann, was?
Ich habe ja einen.
Ich bin froh drum.
Die hatte ich noch nie dran.
Nächstes Mal
weiss ich es hoffentlich.
Ich hätte mir besser erst
die Nase geputzt.
Das wäre nicht schlecht gewesen.
Du kannst gut noch was drauftun.
- Sicher?
Ich bin megafroh,
wenn du mir hilfst.
Du kannst ruhig mehr schmieren.
- Hast du noch ...
Einer muss in der Gruppe
der Clown sein.
Könntest du mir bitte noch
den Spiegel hinhalten, Carmen?
(Carmen) Du kannst ihn anschauen,
ihr seht etwa gleich aus.
Ach, so wie sie?
- Nein, da um die Nüstern rum ...
Ach, die Nüstern ...
- Ist doch gut.
* Eindringliche Musik *
700 m Aufstieg.
Auch die ehemaligen Weltcup-
fahrerinnen sind technisch gefordert.
Schauen wir mal! Er hat mir einen
Tipp für diese Spitzkehre gegeben.
Er ist auch sportlich fit.
Aber wie macht man das jetzt?
Das ist ...
So.
- Aha, mehr so?
Ja, ja.
- Aber nicht zu viel, ja.
Ja, so ... Genau.
So geht's leichter.
Ja, wir machen noch ein paar.
Das lohnt sich.
Danke.
- Der kann natürlich ...
Der macht schon Sport,
sonst würde er das nicht schaffen.
Nah am Erbrechen.
Ausgerechnet Bruno Jelk
leidet heute am meisten.
Er ist es gewohnt,
als Bergführer vorauszugehen,
und kennt die Haute Route bestens.
(David) Steigeisen anziehen,
Felle wegnehmen
und die Skis
auf den Rucksack schnallen!
Bruno, dir geht's nicht gut, was?
Nein. Wenn das nicht besser wird,
hat es keinen Sinn.
Keine Chance?
Aber ... Wollen wir nicht
in der Hütte mal schauen?
Können wir machen, aber wenn's
nicht geht, hat das keinen Sinn.
Ich kotze immer hart, weisst du?
- Aha, ja, ja.
Da bekommt man nicht richtig Luft.
- Ja.
Aber wir gehen jetzt noch ein
bisschen, und dann entscheiden wir.
Wenn's nicht geht, geht's nicht.
- Ja, ja.
Wir schauen mal.
Ich muss einfach langsamer gehen.
Ja. Gut, tipptopp.
Wie geht es mit Bruno weiter?
Die Gruppe ist gross.
Sie braucht zwei Bergführer,
um sicher durch die Woche zu kommen.
* Eindringliche,
majestätische Musik *
Nach 3 Std. ist
der Col du Chardonnet in Griffnähe -
das Tor zu den Walliser Alpen.
(David) Wir sichern den oberen Teil.
Von da an können sie selbst gehen.
3'323 m sind erreicht. Die Grenze
zwischen Frankreich und der Schweiz.
Dahinter: ein steiles Couloir.
Den Karabiner lösen!
Der zweite Teil ist nicht so steil.
Haltet euch am Fixseil fest
und geht runter!
Aber lauft hier oben auch,
sonst kann ich euch auch abseilen.
Rückwärts runtergehen?
- So seitwärts.
Oder rückwärts - wie du willst.
- Gut.
Das ist keine Hexerei.
Wir gehen gleich zusammen. - Gut.
David sichert die Passage
mit einem Seil.
Man muss einfach
nicht zu schnell runterlassen.
Yolanda macht den Anfang.
Am Anfang ist es ziemlich steil,
aber unten können sie
dem Fixseil allein folgen.
Seil frei!
Danke. Du kannst gemütlich losgehen.
- Ja, ist gut.
Für Yolanda
ist der Abstieg kein Problem,
denn sie ist SAC-Tourenleiterin.
Es ist gewaltig. Was will man mehr?
Schönstes Wetter überall.
Da unten sind ein paar Wolken.
Und dann so coole Sachen machen.
Mit den Skis, nicht runtertrotten.
Ist es bis jetzt gut gegangen?
- Ja, ja.
Als Nächstes
ist ihr Vater Paul an der Reihe.
(David) Gut.
Ja, schön breit stehen. Tipptopp.
Paul seilt sich
nicht zum ersten Mal ab.
(Paul) Nein, nein.
- Nein, nein.
Er hat schon einige Kilometer
abgeseilt.
Und der Papa?
- Ja, das geht gut.
Hier runter,
das ist für ihn nicht so schlimm.
Die blöde Abfahrt heute Morgen
war für ihn das Schlimmste.
Dieses Steinharte.
(David) Okay, Paul,
du kannst entlasten, lösen
und gemütlich weitergehen!
So.
Geht's gut?
- Ja, ja.
Oben wartet Peter.
Nervös, aber zuversichtlich.
Gut.
Du hast dich auch schon abgeseilt.
- Nein.
Das ist nicht nur für mich eine
Visitenkarte, sondern auch für dich.
Das stimmt. Hast du das Geschirr
richtig geschlossen? Gut.
Also, einfach schön aufrecht stehen
und breitbeinig rückwärts gehen.
Ich mache am Anfang schön langsam.
- Ja, gerne.
Ich gebe mir Mühe. Und die Richtung?
- Bravo, gut gemacht!
Das geht gut.
- Du kannst ruhig hochschauen.
Nicht auf die Füsse schauen!
(David) Gut! Gut, Peter!
(Yolanda) Super, Peter!
Du kannst entlasten, das grüne Seil
lösen und dem Fixseil folgen.
Langsam!
Gut!
Ein weiterer Schritt hin zum Mut.
Auch Fränzi macht sich bereit.
In der Sache
bin ich etwas pedantisch.
Ich hasse es,
wenn die Brille dreckig ist.
Hast du entschieden,
welches Glas du reintust?
Jetzt habe ich nur noch eins,
aber früher war das am Vorabend
eines Rennens ein Ritual.
Ja, ja. Es musste immer sauber sein.
Jetzt wäre es wohl
nicht mehr so entscheidend, aber ...
Sauber?
Ja, ich fahre schon ...
Ich fahre schon gerne Verschiedenes.
Aber es wäre ...
Es wäre sicher eine Herausforderung.
Es wäre nicht völlig alltäglich.
Aber deswegen sind wir ja hier.
Die Olympiasiegerin
bringt sich in Position.
Als Einzige wagt Dominique Gisin
die Abfahrt
im engen und steilen Couloir.
(David) Fahren!
* Spannende, heroische Musik *
Hier sind all die Steine.
Einen Sturz am Anfang der Tour
möchte sich Dominique nicht leisten -
sie, die in ihrer Heimat Engelberg
oft Freeriding macht.
Ja, unten ist es
etwas mühsam mit den Skis.
Das ist schon nicht
der höchste Spassfaktor.
Aber oben war's cool.
Yolanda nutzt die Pause für eine SMS.
Ja, kurz schauen,
ob es den Kindern gut geht.
Ich schicke ihnen ein Küsschen.
Die Bilder gehen nicht raus,
aber sie bekommen zumindest
ein Küsschen von mir.
Ich habe gesagt:
"Wenn ich die Chance bekomme,
nehme ich mir diese Auszeit jetzt."
Meine Mutter hat gesagt:
"Mach's, wenn du die Chance hast!"
"Ist gut. Mach's!"
Es war dann schon immer wieder so:
"Ja, soll ich wirklich?"
"Darf ich das als Mutter?"
Aber ... ja.
Ich bin jetzt hier und es ist gut.
Und den Kindern
geht's sicher auch gut.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Die Gruppe
ist jetzt seit 5 Std. unterwegs.
Die Sonne brennt auf den Gletscher.
Es geht hinauf
zum nächsten Felsübergang,
zum Fenetre de Saleinaz.
Das ist ein ziemliches Loch hier.
Hast du das gesehen?
Vorbei
an offenen Gletscherspalten.
Ein Fehltritt
kann fatale Folgen haben.
Geht's, Paul?
- Ja, geht schon.
Pass auf, dass du nicht abrutschst!
- Ja, warte!
Versuch, aufzustehen!
Geh ihm mal helfen!
Yolanda hilft ihrem Vater.
(David) Damit das gerade wird.
- Die Steighilfe muss draussen sein.
Dann geht's besser. So, jetzt.
- Vielleicht geht's besser.
Zur Sicherheit
zieht die Gruppe die Steigeisen an.
Ich probier's mal,
sonst schnallen wir sie auf!
(Yolanda) Ist gut, wenn ich ...
- (David) Ja, das geht nicht.
Gut.
- Aufschnallen!
Aber nicht direkt vor dem Loch!
Hier aufbinden!
(David) Jetzt wissen wir ja,
wie man die Steigeisen anzieht.
Und oben machen wir eine Pause. Gut?
(Severin) David, die Felle weg?
- Äh ...
Wartet noch!
Wir machen oben sowieso eine Pause.
Peter,
zieh die Steigeisen richtig an!
David nimmt Pauls Ski.
Yolanda geht auch ohne Steigeisen.
* Eindringliche, pulsierende Musik *
Es folgen
weitere 100 m steiler Aufstieg
bis zum Fenetre de Saleinaz -
mit Ski und Gepäck auf dem Buckel.
Der Schnee
wird durch die Hitze immer weicher.
Die Gruppe hat bereits
einige Höhenmeter in den Beinen,
und es ist erst
der zweite Tag der Tour.
Vater und Tochter sind die Ersten.
(Yolanda) Super!
* Paul keucht. *
Perfekt.
Jetzt ist es noch wärmer.
- Noch wärmer, ja.
Aber es ist besser gegangen,
als ich dachte.
Wie geht's Bruno?
- Tja ...
Es wird schon,
aber gerade mit der Hitze ...
Es schlaucht ihn schon,
aber es wird schon.
Schau, da kommt Peter!
Peter, steh auf!
Gut, ja. Es geht einfacher,
wenn du aufrecht bist.
Komm, noch drei Schritte! Schön.
Ah! Das war sehr anstrengend.
Alles gut?
- Alles gut, aber anstrengend.
* Stimmengewirr *
(Fränzi) Ich bin wirklich
etwas neidisch auf euch zwei.
Dass du das mit Papa machen kannst,
ist cool.
Das würde ich wirklich gern machen.
Aber dafür
müsste ich noch mal herkommen.
Aber vielleicht finden wir
ja irgendeine andere Route.
Bruno Jelk - der Mann, der es
schon ein Leben lang gewohnt ist,
auf der ganzen Welt Leben zu retten -
hat im Aufstieg
sein Gepäck abgeben müssen.
Bruno, wie geht's dir?
- Ja, mühsam, nicht?
Ich glaube, ich tausche wieder
mit dem Aspiranten.
Das bringt mehr.
Also, ich gehe noch auf den Berg da.
David plant derweil
eine zusätzliche Klettertour.
Bis auf den Gipfel?
- Ja, den mittleren.
Das geht auch wieder so hoch.
- Oben ist es Felsklettern.
Meinst du, ich schaff das?
- Ja.
2 Std. hin und zurück? Wir müssen
noch für die nächsten Tage ...
Ja, morgen ist schon noch ...
Ach, komm doch einfach mit!
- Ich kann ja sonst stehen bleiben.
Sonst musst du mich einfach
aushalten. Ich werde mühsam.
(Dominique) Du kannst sonst
bei mir im Skidepot bleiben.
Ja, also gut.
- Gut, dann machen wir's so.
Dann gehen Paul und Peter
mit Bruno zurück.
Wer noch Kraft und Energie hat,
will sich den zusätzlichen Gipfel
nicht entgehen lassen.
Ja, sehr gern.
Hast du noch Platz?
Hast du deine Waden eingecremt?
- Ja, habe ich.
Denn sonst ...
Das ist nicht meins.
- (Peter) Darf ich's haben?
* Klagender Frauengesang *
Der Gipfel,
so verlockend er aussieht,
ist nicht für alle realistisch.
Bruno fährt mit Paul und Peter
über den Gletscher
direkt zur Cabane du Trient.
Während die anderen weiter
zur Aiguille du Tour aufsteigen.
Inzwischen ist es Mittag.
Die Sonne brennt vom Himmel.
Nach dem eiskalten Morgen
herrschen auf 3'000 m Höhe
jetzt Sommertemperaturen.
Die Trinkflaschen sind fast leer,
der Proviant gegessen.
Die Hitze setzt allen zu.
Auch Olympiasiegerin Dominique Gisin
kämpft.
Auch das steht nicht im Lehrbuch.
Und die Kletterpartie
steht noch bevor.
Wir lassen die Rucksäcke hier.
Könnt ihr irgendwie ...
Sicherung machen?
- Nein, da passiert nichts.
Die Steigeisen ans Geschirr hängen.
Jetzt ist mir auch klar,
warum es nie abwärts geht.
Es geht ja einfach nur rüber.
Scheisse!
Jetzt muss ich was trinken.
Ich habe solchen Durst.
Carmen, ist es anstrengend?
Euch sollte man
einen Fragenkatalog geben -
mit besseren Fragen.
Ja, ich bin patschnass.
Jetzt geht's am Anfang
einfach etwas zu schnell,
oder es ist einfach genug.
Ja. Ich glaube, ich merke auch,
dass wir nie so richtig
länger Pause machen.
Aber ich habe jetzt dann eine, weil
ich ja nicht mit raufgehen muss.
Carmen, was ist dein Plan?
Was mein Plan ist?
- Ja.
An einem Rucksack vorbeigehen
und eine Trinkflasche rausholen,
das wäre das Beste.
- Aber du kommst mit auf den Gipfel?
Ja, so weit es eben geht.
- Wir gehen gemütlich.
Handschuhe mitnehmen?
Zieh sie nicht an,
aber nimm sie mit!
Peter, Bruno und Paul
sind fast schon am Ziel.
Die Cabane du Trient
ist ein alter Steinbau,
die erste Hütte auf Schweizer Boden.
Übernachtet wird auf 3'170 m.
Bruno, geht's?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht erholen.
Ich kann nicht erbrechen, weisst du?
Hat sich das mit dem Laufen
nicht verbessert?
Nein. Ich muss mich abkämpfen, damit
ich einigermassen mithalten kann.
Als erfahrener Bergführer kennt Bruno
die Strapazen der Haute Route
und weiss: Wer nicht 100%ig fit ist,
kann die Tour nicht durchstehen.
Ich dachte:
"Ja, die Woche ist noch lang."
Darum ist für heute genug.
Paul?
- Für mich ... * Räuspern *
Für mich ist es einfach,
weil die Woche noch lang ist.
Diesen Gipfel muss ich
nicht unbedingt gehabt haben.
Ich muss meine Kräfte
für die ganze Woche schonen,
also einteilen.
Und morgen wird auch wieder happig.
Ich hatte ja zwei Hüftoperationen.
Da habe ich einen
ziemlichen Rückschlag erlitten.
Ich habe natürlich schon
Training eingebüsst,
also dort eine Einbusse erlebt.
Das merke ich auch.
Er spricht von Kräfte einteilen -
das merke ich auch.
Es ist auch mit 56 nicht mehr so,
wie es mal war, ganz klar.
Inzwischen ist David mit
seiner Gruppe kurz vor dem Gipfel.
Schön, wie im Sommer.
Alle sind mitgekommen, auch Carmen.
Durst. Ist es klug,
aus dieser Gosse zu trinken?
David,
darf ich aus dieser Pfütze trinken?
Nein, das mache ich nicht.
- (Fränzi) Trink einfach!
Also, ich trinke einfach.
- (David) Du kannst auch lecken.
Da unten ist noch ein Molch.
(Fränzi, lachend)
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Nein.
* Schlürfen *
Sie trinkt.
Ja.
Nach über 7 Std. ist
der erste Gipfel der Tour erreicht.
Gratuliere. Danke vielmals.
Gratuliere.
Gratuliere auch.
- Gratuliere.
Wie hoch ist der?
- Ich habe ...
... 3'534.
- 3'500.
Das ist gut. Und wie heisst er?
- Aiguille du Tour.
Du Tour? Mhm.
Vielleicht fragt dich mal jemand.
- Eine ziemliche Tour.
(David)
Aber die Aussicht ist grandios.
Ich bin froh, wenn wir runtergehen.
Ich kann nicht so rumschauen.
Ist in Ordnung.
- Bereust du es jetzt?
Vielleicht morgen, wenn ich
Blasen und Muskelkater habe.
Der Aufstieg war nicht so schlimm
von der Kraft her.
Das Hochtreten war anstrengender.
Ganz gemütlich. Dominique,
du musst dich einfach beschweren!
Ja, ja, ich jammere dann schon.
Vielleicht sehen wir einander noch.
- Hoffen wir's.
Danke sehr und ganz gute Besserung.
Danke.
- Und sonst in Zermatt. Danke auch.
Schweren Herzens
hat Bruno entschieden,
mit dem Heli, der für Kamerateams
und Transport zuständig ist,
ins Tal zu fliegen.
Es geht nicht mehr, was?
- Heute jedenfalls nicht.
Es hat keinen Wert.
Hier oben erholt man sich nicht,
und morgen noch einmal
hinterherlaufen bringt's nicht.
Mit David hast du ja gesprochen.
- Ja, ja.
Bruno fühlt sich nicht mehr
in der Lage, weiterzumachen,
und hofft,
dass er sich in Zermatt erholen kann,
um vielleicht später
noch einmal zurückzukommen.
(David) Gut, fahren! Kommt!
Währenddessen freut sich Davids
Gruppe auf eine lange Abfahrt.
(Carmen) Ui, nein!
Ich habe noch die Gehfunktion drin.
Du solltest langsam wissen,
dass ich blond bin.
Du könntest wirklich aufpassen.
So blöd!
Au Mann!
* Majestätische,
eindringliche Musik *
Eine Entschädigung
für all die Strapazen.
Juhui, endlich!
Nach über 8 Std.
werden die Gipfelstürmer
in der Cabane du Trient erwartet.
Zeig mal eine Dose!
- Das macht sie fertig.
Nein, im Gegenteil.
Wollt ihr ein Bier haben?
- Was?
Ein Bier?
- Hauptsache, was zu trinken.
Das würde ich auch meinen.
- Es gibt Cola.
Ihr könnt die Ski hier ausziehen.
Ihr müsst sie nachher runtertragen.
Ihr seid Schätze.
- Hier.
Ah, danke.
- Super.
Danke vielmals.
- Hey, bravo.
Danke.
- Zum Wohl! Bravo!
Danke vielmals.
- Bravo.
Angekommen. Zum Wohl!
Ja, es war schön.
- Wart ihr alle oben?
Ja.
- Gut.
Heiss, aber schön.
- Heiss, aber schön.
Gratuliere. Prost!
- Ja, cheers!
Heiss. Ich habe am Morgen
nicht genug getrunken.
Als es so warm wurde, merkte ich,
dass ich mega durstig wurde.
Ich kippte alles runter,
was ich hatte, und noch mehr,
aber dort drüben
hatte ich schon wieder nichts mehr.
Jetzt bin ich einfach
mit dem Wasser am Anschlag.
Total dehydriert also?
- Ja, es ist einfach so heiss.
Wirklich abartig.
Ich bin nicht
für diese Wärme gemacht.
(Fränzi ) Um morgens
für 5 Min. nicht frieren zu müssen,
war mir jetzt 6 Std. zu heiss.
So lernt man.
(David)
Du hattest Recht mit deinem Papa.
Ich weiss,
ich kann mich auf ihn verlassen.
Auf dem Gipfel sagte sie,
der Papa sei gut dressiert.
Der warte mit Getränken.
- Prost! Danke vielmals.
(Paul) David, wer kommt noch?
- Carmen. Und Ralph.
Ralph ist ein Kamel. Der braucht ...
Der kann auch drei Tage
ohne Getränke sein.
Ralph Weber, der Bergführer,
der für das Filmteam zuständig ist,
hat sich Carmen angenommen.
(Peter) Es war sicher heiss.
- Ja.
Das wundert mich nicht.
Du, vielen Dank.
- Gerne.
Danke dir.
- Alles Gute! Du hast es geschafft.
Jetzt habe ich es dir über
den Rücken gekippt. Dreh dich um!
Nicht halb so wild.
- Pardon!
Hey, du hast es geschafft.
Bravo! Gratuliere. - Danke.
Ich war zwei-, dreimal so ...
Vom Psychischen her hatte ich
während des Aufstiegs wirklich Mühe.
Ich habe Mühe,
wenn ich an andere angeseilt bin.
Das ist ein wenig wie Platzangst -
nicht weg oder ausweichen können.
Und dann ging es
wirklich ziemlich steil abwärts.
Die Höhe ist auch nicht mein Ding.
Beim Fliegen
hat mir das sehr gefallen,
und auf Bahnen und so
ist es auch so,
aber hier hatte ich wirklich
etwas Mühe damit.
Sante!
- Gesundheit!
Auch CEO Severin Moser
geniesst die Pause.
Hast du bis jetzt mal
deine E-Mails gecheckt?
Nein, habe ich noch nicht.
- Und jetzt?
Jetzt ... schaue ich mal.
Aber ich habe vorhin gesehen,
dass ich keinen Empfang habe.
Für die E-Mails müsste ich
auf diesen Hügel steigen.
Ich habe mich noch nicht
dazu durchringen können.
(Peter) Noch nicht.
- Vielleicht gehe ich noch.
Ich habe aber geschaut,
und ich habe 23 WhatsApps.
Die meisten sind privat,
aber einige sind auch geschäftlich.
Severin Moser
ist ehemaliger Zehnkämpfer
und trainiert noch heute täglich.
Als CEO bei der Allianz Schweiz
führt er 3'500 Mitarbeiter
und hat sich vorgenommen, in dieser
Woche keine Mails zu beantworten.
Es sind 38 E-Mails reingekommen.
- In zwei Tagen?
Ja. Das ist nicht so schlimm, oder?
Wenn ich ehrlich bin,
habe ich ein schlechtes Gewissen,
wenn ich daran denke,
dass die anderen jetzt
in einem Sitzungszimmer sind
und irgendwo da unten im Dunst
eine Sitzung abhalten,
während wir so tolles Wetter
und so ein Panorama haben.
Man darf sich selbst
nicht zu wichtig nehmen.
Man ist ja ein Rädchen
im ganzen Räderwerk.
Natürlich hat man eine exponierte
und wahrscheinlich
wichtige Funktion,
aber jeder ist letztlich ersetzbar.
Wenn man sich
nicht allzu wichtig nimmt,
kann man auch mal
so eine Woche überstehen.
Zu ersetzen ist nun Bruno Jelk.
Mit seinem Abgang hat das Team
den zweiten Bergführer verloren.
Jetzt haben wir eben das Problem,
dass Bruno uns verlassen musste -
wegen des Magens und ...
Aber so ist es jetzt einfach.
Wie ziehen trotzdem weiter.
Wir haben das besprochen und gesagt,
dass wir ja noch eine erfahrene
Berggängerin dabei haben.
Wenn wir
zwei Seilschaften machen müssen,
ist Yolanda Seilführerin
der zweiten Seilschaft.
Ist das gut für dich?
- Das ist gut für mich.
Ist das gut für euch?
- (Alle) Ja.
Aber morgen versuchen wir,
ein wenig Ski zu fahren,
nicht nur zu traversieren.
- Yes!
Ist das gut? Passt das?
- Super, ja, das passt.
David will
mit SAC-Tourenleiterin Yolanda
vorerst allein weitermachen
und hofft,
dass Bruno wieder fit wird.
* Klagender Frauengesang *
Am nächsten Morgen
ist um 4.30 Uhr Tagwache.
Das ist keine Philosophie.
Fränzi ist eher ein Morgenmensch.
Man sieht nichts.
Jeden Tag übernachtet die Gruppe
gemeinsam in einer anderen Hütte.
Der Ablauf des Morgens
folgt einem Ritual.
Zuerst wird der Rucksack gepackt.
Das Gepäck für eine Woche
tragen alle selbst -
ein Rucksack wiegt mit Steigeisen
und Pickel bis zu 10 kg.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Bevor es losgeht, werden
die Lawinensuchgeräte kontrolliert.
* Piepen *
Sind alle da?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
Yolanda macht die LVS-Kontrolle.
Ich gehe gleich als Erster.
Paul folgt mir nach, und wir warten
da unten auf der Fläche.
Jeder muss bei Yolanda vorbeifahren.
Ein Piepen zeigt an, dass die
Lawinensuchgeräte eingeschaltet sind.
* Piepen *
Gut.
Das Wetter ist bisher stabil,
und auch die Prognosen sehen gut aus.
Wieder stehen rund 6 Std.
Aufstieg, Traversen und Abfahrten
in über 3'000 m Höhe bevor.
* Klagender Frauengesang *
Die kalten Morgenstunden
sind wichtig und geben Sicherheit.
Die Gruppe muss gegen 14 Uhr
in der nächsten Hütte sein,
da es am Nachmittag
wieder heiss werden soll
und damit die Gefahr
von Nassschneelawinen steigt.
Dann ein abfallendes Steilstück
mit einer Schneeverwehung,
einer Wechte.
Ich glaube, es geht da lang.
Ich schaue dann nachher.
Gut.
Wir können die Felle ausziehen ...
... und aufs Skifahren umrüsten.
Ich habe immer Respekt
vor solchen Wechten.
Ja, das ...
Das habe ich vorher schon ...
Ich glaube,
wer mal Tourenleiterin gewesen ist,
schaut einfach immer wieder
bei anderen mit.
Unbewusst.
Und jetzt weiss ich,
dass es bewusster ist.
Ja, wir müssen Paul
ein wenig sichern,
aber für die anderen ...
Oder Peter. Für die Skifahrerinnen
ist es sicher kein Problem.
Und dann ... Ja, ja, eben
ein wenig sichern, dann ist es gut.
Und das sehen Sie
in der nächsten Folge:
Ein vereister Steilhang
fordert die Gruppe am frühen Morgen.
(Paul) Ja, eben nicht so gut.
Nicht so gut.
Bewährungsprobe für Yolanda
als Tourenleiterin.
Warte bitte wieder,
bis ich es dir sage!
Gut, du kannst kommen.
Endlich 2'000 m Abfahrt
für die beiden Weltcupfahrerinnen
Dominique Gisin
und Fränzi Aufdenblatten ...
... sowie ein Bekenntnis.
Es ist wie im normalen Leben auch.
Ich glaube, mit manchen
wird es wirklich eine Freundschaft
und mit anderen kommst du gut aus,
aber es ist nicht so,
dass wir zusammen in die Ferien
gegangen wären. - Nein.
Und Peter kommt ins Grübeln.
Dann fängt es an, im Kopf zu drehen:
"Wer bin ich?"
"Was mache ich hier überhaupt?
Gehöre ich in die Gruppe?"
"Wieso will ich nicht mitreden?"
Dies und mehr gleich im zweiten Teil
von "Abenteuer Alpen -
die Skitour des Lebens".